hello and welcome to this video on
playing Bisou Bisou never playing right
now so yeah just looking for a different
kind of position this is not too bad I
mean it's a quite a respectable setup
with black connectors reversed on Knight
f3 g3 playing with a 675 is quite is
quite respectable and played by the
grandmasters okay I wanted to prevent
him to play d5 okay I don't prevent it
entirely he can still do it take um e 5
takes 94 97 this is always possible
interesting interesting
ok
P takes D takes d5 is got e6 okay that
doesn't really do much so I'm just going
to support it
I wonder how to react after C takes d4 I
should take with the pawn you might have
d5 and then I go c5 you know it's an
interesting structure probably probably
Black is fine down but they'll be
interesting to see how that turns out
yeah I have to judge I'm an IQ p
position with a three before and the
bishop on b2 is just stupid silly
so c5 and now I've got this majority and
have a decent grip on e5 he can however
put the light on to e4 or something with
Bishop g4 94 and so on
yeah this is a good starting move of
course
yeah where do we go here ship d3 I want
them all to be five sometimes taking as
an option but I don't think this is
supplying here maybe I can get
additional control over your form go
Bishop d3
hmm
mmm the shoe g4 is annoying really okay
let's prevent it it is oh it would have
been in particular annoying with them
with a bishop on d3 then that Bishop
then Bishop g4 is a a real pin
okay the show takes h3 is not going to
work
in 92 he's got night xf2 discovery one
day arc we need to maybe then 92 I need
to put more pressure here
he's got he five Scottie five but I mean
I think I can just take a couple of
times and then play Knight f3 yeah that
is that's fine actually unless there is
some some no I don't I don't think
Bishop takes h3 is ever going to work
unless I mean unless things change
dramatically would okay he takes a lot
of time but I can definitely just take
on d-21 like take on d2 and take on d3
and and be okay and he takes some spends
a lot of time IAM that is interesting
yeah but I think not too unhappy about
it it gives it gives up a little bit of
flexibility okay the night wants to go
to your form that is very obvious I'm
trying to be ready for this play Bishop
g5 okay just in case it's got v6 or
something
okay you also move the rook away so that
it's not a pin hmm it's something that
that I should have spotted okay not a
big deal but still should have seen it
yeah so now the night doesn't have many
squares how do we do that
look him and then night 2 D 3 and then F
3 M that is the thing that looks awkward
really for the bishop here
oh no it's got 93
now I was a vet for sylia that was a
silly mistake on my part it is still a
playable position because of the pawns
he take take
I take here it's got route d8 even
Wow just playing very well in this guy
no I wanted to go chief oh of course
[ __ ] it doesn't matter really but it's
not a game you should lose really not me
I didn't see Knight f5 I mean I think
black was basically in bad shape them
that just doesn't work I cannot put a
knight on to g3 and stuff I just should
take first and then play 93 it just just
not a good position I had simply
overlooked this move and then he played
this very well if Ibis is extremely
strong and not not obvious to me at
least you could prepare it but it is
very strong and the the main thing is
that here rook c5 I mean yeah I might be
lost but I can still try am NOT King a6
I am I cannot try right now that is that
is just stronger King e6 rook c5 and so
on that is stuff bad stuff night I
shouldn't lose this especially after a
forum I think from some from here on
like is it's just slowly outplayed but
90 of 5 is just stupid to miss you
shouldn't do that but here should play
Bishop g5 maybe maybe it's better but I
mean I'm just completely controlling
this position so that's just not a big
deal can you can play like that a force
actually given by the comp and and then
within blacks position sucks
if you have to play this this weird move
this you can even debate about their
king of 193 mm-hmm yeah that's even
stronger yeah I just couldn't believe
that the night would be good there and
it isn't yeah but okay if I take I'm
definitely better but not they are not
winning or anything and this I
overlooked yeah but when he converted
this very very convincing name hmm
yeah that's annoying I just did not see
Knight f5 I mean I was probably relaxing
too much because he was down on eight
seconds or something but it doesn't
matter really if you blend that into
this and then then you can play all
those quick moves okay guys thanks for
watching